in washington president biden signed a
massive bill called the inflation
reduction act into law after months of
negotiations it includes ambitious
measures to address climate change and
health care costs ed o'keefe is at the
white house ed good morning nate good to
see you the white house and democrats
overall now think they've got something
good to sell to voters the inflation
reduction act includes the largest ever
federal spending to combat climate
change it would reduce health care costs
or keep them lower for many people on
medicare and the affordable care act and
it's paid for with new taxes on billion
dollar companies that right now pay
almost nothing to the u s government in
taxes the legislation was made possible
after a deal was struck with west
virginia senator joe manchin who was on
hand to receive the pen from the
president that's quite the picture right
there mr biden also gave a preview of
what to anticipate this fall campaign
season
the bill i'm about to sign is not just
about today it's about tomorrow it's
about delivering progress and prosperity
to american families
it's about showing the american and the
american people that democracy still
works in america
once this vacation is over next week the
president and members of his cabinet are
scheduled to attend dozens of events and
at least 23 states to talk about the
plan and they'll be directly or
indirectly campaigning for fellow
democrats one person though who won't be
out anytime soon is the first lady dr
jill biden tested positive for kovitt 19
yesterday she is going to stay at the
home in south carolina that the bidens
used for the first part of their
vacation and will leave there when she
tests negative twice the president for
now
is in nearby delaware at their home
there
tony all right ed thank you very much